Black Mirror showcases the possibilities
of what our future might look like but
some of those Futures have already come
to pass in unexpected ways these
episodes are the acclaimed Anthology
series are eerily reminiscent of
real-life development
15 million merits is Black Mirror at its
best the second episode of the series
stars Daniel kaluya as Bing a man living
in a hyper capitalist dystopia his life
is defined by the number of merits he
has points that function as currency and
are earned by riding a stationary bike
to produce energy a pearl of toothpaste
in the morning costs five merits
skipping video ads costs more and
they're everywhere not even the bathroom
is safe when Bing tries to free his
co-worker Abby from this literal cycle
of exploitation by entering her into a
talent show she ends up being pressured
into an adult film career as an escape
from the drudgery of the bikes when Bing
then goes on the show and preaches
against a system of threatening to
graphically illustrate how dedicated he
is to proving his point his desperate
run to such a ratings boost that he's
given his own TV show
we sing and dance and Tumble around and
all and all you see up here is not it's
not people you don't see people up here
it's all fodder it's a reflection of the
way that capitalism subsumes critiques
of itself turning revolutionary
sentiment into a consumer product on the
surf first the episode of functions are
the razor sharp critique of our economic
system and the way it objectifies people
transforming them into Commodities but
it also takes things a step further
speculating that technology will enable
capitalists rent seeking on an
unprecedented scale indeed in the years
since 15 million merits aired we have
seen the rise of digital
microtransactions the trend is most
prevalent in video games where in-game
items can be purchased for small amounts
of money but it has spread Elsewhere on
Amazon you can buy things with a single
click we pay monthly fees to access
media libraries on Netflix and Spotify
but we don't own the songs or movies it
may be only a matter of time until we
pay for toothpaste by the dollop
in the entire history of view marital
infidelity is exposed due to a skull
implant called a grain that allows users
to record everything they see and hear
when Liam suspects his wife fion of
cheating on him he goes on a
self-destructive rampage that culminates
with him taking a rather drastic step to
stop the recording process you know when
you suspect something
it's always better when it turns out to
be true while implant technology is
nowhere near being a reality the episode
still got quite a lot right about the
future of tech two years after a Ted
Google announced Google Glass a headset
the size of a pair of glasses with a
camera mounted on the front however the
device was too ahead of its time in 2013
the general public clearly wasn't ready
for a world where anyone could be
recorded at any time as some people
began to harass and assault Google Glass
users in public then in 2016 billionaire
Elon Musk launched his company nor a
link in an effort to make brain implants
happen so far the project has gone
nowhere with little to show for its
efforts except for a whole lot of dead
monkeys however the constant
self-surveillance depicted in the entire
history of you has come true in spirit
smartphone cameras continue to get
better and many people meticulously
amass their day-to-day doings and
Instagram stories and Snapchat archives
we don't need brain implants to obsess
over our digitally documented purse
white Christmas is probably the darkest
holiday special ever made starring John
Ham and Ray Spore this two men forced to
share a cabin on Christmas the final
twist in this story is that the pair are
actually trapped in a simulation as
punishment for crimes they committed in
real life Pam's character match friends
steals a show as a man whose day job was
to program smart home controllers while
Moonlighting as a virtual coach
romantically inept man while the latter
job definitely reflects some creepy
realities of the internet age Ham's main
job early predicted the rise of
smartphone Voice assistance the smart
home controllers and white Christmas are
called cookies and they work a lot like
Amazon's Alexa with one major difference
instead of a robot cookies are powered
by a copy of the homeowner's
Consciousness which is forced to
automate the household should the copied
person refuse they're punished by having
their sense of time altered one minute
in reality could equate to A Thousand
Years in the machine that's slavery
it's a little melodramatic isn't it she
thought she was real
but she wasn't it's barbaric ultimately
though the cookies depicted in White
Christmas are unrealistic not just
because transferring human consciousness
into a computer remains an impossibility
but even if it were possible it would be
far more inefficient than current smart
home assistant who wants an imprisoned
version of yourself that must be coaxed
and tortured into running your smart
home when you can just have a robot do
it without the ethical conundrums and
hassle in men against fire the fifth
episode of the third season of Black
Mirror a soldier called stripe is
touched with eradicating mutant humans
known as roaches after his military
issued augmented reality implant
glitches though he realizes the Dark
Truth roaches are not mutants but rather
regular humans belonging to A persecuted
ethnic minority stripers been killing
them as part of an ongoing genocide all
this time the plus of this episode is an
allegory for the ways in which people
can be misled into hatred of a
vulnerable group and for health
technology can accelerate that hatred we
tend to think that we are more evolved
than our ancestors due to our
technological advancements but men
against fire lays bare the truth that
technology can be used to inflame
tribalistic Prejudice it can amplify
messages of hatred and to sort our
perception of those who are different
from us malicious actors can use
technology to spread dehumanizing
propaganda
easier to pull the trigger when you're
aiming at the boogeyman